Film Courage: Eli, where does a great story
begin for you? Long Beach City College Film
Professor/Filmmaker, Elias Daughdrill: Oh boy, I
don’t know? That’s a hard question to start with,
where does it begin? Do you mean something that
I’m writing or something that I’m experiencing,
something that I’m watching? Film Courage: Could
be both. Maybe think of a movie that really
drew you into your love for film. Elias:
I guess it’s not necessarily this,
it’s not necessarily the story that engages me,
it’s more the point of view. I think point of
view is the most important thing because I
think that we tell a lot of the same stories
but it is the way that they are told, the
way that they are executed that makes them
interesting or makes them unique and I think
that’s the thing that i respond to and that's
the thing that i'm most conscious of is what
is my point of view in trying to tell a story
what am i trying to get at that's different
than someone else's approach to the story so
it's that it's the their view of the world and
that point of view can be political it can be
apolitical it can be um philosophical it's um
it's the uniqueness of the of the perspective
of the person telling the story that i think
is the the most critical yeah like if you think
about uh reality tv and the dating shows and
then you take something like sherman's march
i know that's going back a few years but no it's a
great film it's excellent and just seeing the guys
i was it's ross and ross okay uh his his like
hesitance and his falling in love and then
falling in love with someone new and then being in
this small town and all the expectations with that
and then you could see the exact same thing
and we'll leave the name of the shows out but
something about the way that ross did it was so
natural i could have watched another three hours
of it yeah i mean the way he's he is not afraid
to let um his intention devolve um and i mean i
even wouldn't even have to talk about a different
subject matter you could certainly i'm sure there
have been multiple films or television shows that
have been made about sherman's march that are just
a kind of straight what we might call expository
retelling of the history right and so um
those may have value or may not have value
but i think what makes um that film um
sort of so memorable memorable is because
that approach he's not afraid to let
this that's going to be about oh i meant this
other girl today you know and also he lets um
uh one scene from that it's really interesting
i haven't thought about that film in a long
time but you bring up one scene when i think of
that film that stands out is there's two women
in the kitchen talking about you know we talking
about civil war and they lost but when that war
when it comes again we're going to be ready for
it this time or something like that and so he's
um he's still delving into the history he's
still delving into the sort of cultural wounds
that are there that are present but also telling
this great really funny really unexpected that's
that's absolutely a great example of a kind of
uniqueness of point of view um that you would
not expect when you're watching um a movie that's
supposedly about sherman's march why it's three
hours long yeah and you're like i could take
another three hours of this it's so good yeah
yeah no he's great he's really interesting um he's
an interesting guy he's just he's a fun guy to
listen to um yeah and sorry what expository
can you just explain so expository is like
um bill nichols is this um he's actually a former
professor of mine he was up at san francisco state
and um uh he was at one time considered one
of the foremost authorities maybe he still is
i don't know on documentary film and so he broke
down what he called the modes of documentary film
um and the different their different approaches to
trying to find the their notion of truth and one
of them is what's called expository an expository
mode so an expository mode is a mode that believes
in a kind of absolute truth and tries to just
relay facts to the audience members so that those
facts might come through um title cards that give
us factual information it might come through in a
sort of authoritative voiceover or someone is
giving you this is when this happened this is
what this is going on but it is a it's a treatment
of the documentary world and this notion of truth
as absolute and the film's job is to deliver those
truths through those facts to you via different
techniques or talking head interviews for instance
you get an expert to come in and say this is what
happened this is why it happened all that sort of
stuff and um so you could absolutely see a film
a documentary about sherman's sermons march that
takes that kind of tact where here's a historian
historian's going to talk about it and we'll
give you some voice over and we'll give you some
title cards that'll give you the facts of when
this happened and when that happened whereas um
mcelwee it's much more subjective it might even
be called what we what nichols calls performative
where it's all about the personal it's all
about the subjective um so yeah that's that's um
again i think that's what makes that it's so
interesting was that some of what was done with
60 minutes i know i'm dating myself with that one
but i can remember it as a style yeah absolutely
yeah you know or if you i mean if you look at if
you look at uh sort of documentaries especially
from the 40s and 50s that's the stuff that kind
of dominated that kind of expository style or
even something like march of the penguins like
is to use somewhat more contemporary example
um no no no no i'm not picking on you i'm myself
i'm like okay let me think of something here
um uh you know that there is we're going to
teach you facts here's facts about penguins and
here's facts about how penguins mate and their
whole cycle what they do throughout the year
and we're going to use morgan freeman's voice to
give you that information and that way there's
something about selecting morgan freeman
knowing that the audience is going to trust
him right he's going to deliver this factual
information and the audience will take it as
facts as the truth you know that's a very
expository style which is way different
than like the film i mentioned before um turn on
the camera stories we tell sarah paulie's movie
which is a really really interesting use of
a kind of performative style where she does
these reenactments but you don't know that
the reenactments when you're watching them
and she's she's very much throughout the course
of the film questioning the notion of what the
truth is here she's trying to retell the
story of how of her family essentially
and there's also an extreme danger with that
because you could think back to like propaganda
films yeah of the 40s and 30s and things like
that yeah well i mean like uh you get into um
you do you get into question notions of what is
the truth but um this here you get into ethical
sort of dilemma of um what your role is as a
documentary filmmaker and what um what you owe
i guess what you're supposed to try to achieve
some would say in this kind of 6 60-minute style
that we're trying to to delve into this kind of
the absolute truth and trying to figure that out
whereas others um might say that there's no way to
do that it's impossible there's no way to sort of
remove yourself one of the ways i if i'm lecturing
on documentary film one of the things that i'll
talk about is how it's impossible to remove
bias um there's no such thing as sort of um
an unmediated film meaning you
are a documentary film you can't
remove your own perspective no matter how hard
you try the example i i'll give is you know if i
if i decide that i'm going to make a film
about long beach city college students right
um that's what i've decided i'm going to do and
there's like 30 000 students that attend this
school there's no way i can talk to all 30 000
students so i'm just going to talk to this class
of 80 kids 80 students but even talking to 80
students is too difficult so i'm just going to
take the first two rows which is like 15 students
and i'm going to talk to those 15 students and
when i'm doing those those interviews i discover
that this student over here is not interesting
on camera at all they're boring so i can't use
them i've got to cut them out but this student
over here is really interesting so she's going
to be all over my movie because i think she's
saying all kinds of interesting things and it
aligns with what i think is is um possibly the um
proper perspective about being a long
beach city college student so then i
pose this question to them where's
the first time i showed my bias
by choosing the one interesting
student long before that i showed
my bias when i decided to make a movie
about long beach city college students
because as soon as i just made that choice
as soon as i said that i'm going to make a
film about long beach city college
students i decided not to make a film about
donald trump the automobile cats whatever like
there's a perspective right there i'm saying that
this is interesting this is newsworthy this should
be a film i have just indicated a bias right there
um and so there's no way to separate your point
of view or your perspective or your way of seeing
the world once because you're making choices
immediately when i just decide to pick up the
camera and shoot something i've made a choice um
so i i i always think that those films a film like
stories we tell a film like sherman's march um the
stuff that werner herzog doesn't like grizzly man
those films tend to be for me or aaron morris's
documentary work tend to be the most interesting
because they're the ones that are acknowledging
um that this truth is out here and it's elusive
and i don't know if it actually exists and we can
grab it or not all i can do is present my point of
view and this is all very slippery i don't know
that feels that feels more honest to me than
here's the truth we're gonna give you the truth of
the expository style um i mean there's all kinds
of people who do stuff with with observational
documentary like someone like frederick weissman
is just masterful or the measles brothers
before they died were great at that stuff
was there a period in your life where
you really wanted to understand story
and so you just started consuming all types of
films um i mean it wasn't because i wanted to con
understand stories just i was interested in movies
like i wanted to just watch movies you know it
wasn't necessarily because i'm like oh i need to
figure out how they tell them i mean i i grew up i
grew up in an area where there's not film culture
necessarily and it was pre-digital revolution the
internet existed but i didn't have the internet
at the time um you grew up on a farm i grew up
on a farm and um and so i i do remember at some
point there was i was more interested in like
screenplay structure or um even screenplay format
because i i had you know as a teenager i bought a
couple of scripts from like uh was it barnes
and noble would we have like borders i don't
know one of those book stores in the mall
and the structure of them like what is this
interior you know what is the slug line why are
they written this way and like to figure out
you know i'd written short stories or whatever but
to figure out like how do you write this what does
this look like physically what does this look
like and so i remember transcribing like i had
a videotape of a um an episode of homicide life
on the street you remember that television show
which i loved and i just took one of the shows
you know now i could just google it and probably
find the pdf of the the teleplay somewhere but i
just took that show this episode that i love so
much and i transcribed the whole thing which
meant i was stopping and rewinding that you
know to get all the dialogue and just sort of
okay what does this look like when you actually
write it like okay so this and you can see
or i could see okay so lines of dialogue which is
you know kind of something that we teach now but
i needed to see it because i didn't take any
taking any screenwriting classes or anything
um at that point oh lines of dialogue there's
no like block speeches like this like the lines
of dialogue are four or five words sometimes
less uh often less um and they'll speak this
much and then we go into a new scene it was um it
was just useful to me to try to figure out i mean
long after that i'm still trying to figure out
how to write a script but like j like physically
i needed to physically see it there was something
about physically seeing it and how it looked on a
page because um it's not something that i grew
up looking at or reading right when you read a
a story when you read a novel when you read a
short story it doesn't look like a screenplay
i need to figure out what they look like um
and but then just i watch movies i watch movies
because they ranch the way the way that um a movie
can get you inside of a story and get you inside
of a perspective um that was what was interesting
to me yeah figuring out how to tell them yeah
absolutely like i'm i'm always interested in
that now um and as i've you know started going
when i went to film school and all that sort of
stuff um but i don't ever remember thinking like
this is gonna teach me how to tell a story maybe i
did i don't know but i don't remember it if i did
did you have plans to study film i mean growing up
you grew up in like central california i grew up
in central california um it was a discovery i made
as a teenager um that um oh i'm interested in this
like from not having a social life
and just watching lots of movies
and i grew up in a um a pretty religious household
and we actually didn't have a vcr and you know i'm
a child of the eighties i think you said junior
generation x i'm generic gen x just like you
and um so watching videos on at
home on your vcr was a big way of
consuming movies for our generation and i didn't
have that available to me but what we would do is
my mother if we had like uh you know she
has three sons none of whom want to get
up earlier than 11 a.m on the weekend but
she would give us like you know if we do
this big chore like wash all the windows around
the house we could then go to the video store
and we could rent a bunch of movies and also
we'd rent a vcr because we didn't have one
and so this would be an opportunity for me and
my brothers to just rent a bunch of stuff that we
had wanted to see but hadn't had the opportunity
um and so that really sort of sparked something
because the they became um it's not just the the
movies themselves but the this pleasure this thing
that was not available to me but then we would
have this these kind of days of ecstasy where
we got to see a bunch of stuff so i'll never
forget like die hard when i rented die hard
i watched that thing in the course of a 24
hour period i must have watched it four times
um you know i was watching it two weeks because i
was the young i'm the youngest and so i went last
you know my brothers got their picks and they
watched their film so i'm staying up till one
or two in the morning to watch die hard and then
i think i woke up early the next day at 8 00 a.m
or whatever to watch it again um and i still
love that movie to this day it's a masterpiece
um so that sparked something that
kind of experience and then just yeah
just being an awkward teenager and not having
much of a social life most of my friday nights
were spent after we did finally get a vcr uh
most of my friday and saturday nights were spent
renting stuff you know um yeah i grew up in a
small town so like um the movies that i started
to get interested in as a teenager they didn't
come to our um theaters so if i was gonna see
you know reservoir dogs or something like that
it was gonna be on video it was not going to be
at the local theater although i yeah that
was like as i'm sort of growing into um
going into this as a main focal interest and
trying to get my friends interested and they
were not i mean they like going to the movies but
they didn't want to necessarily make movies and
they definitely didn't want to see these like um
already the stuff that i would already films that
i was into so i'll never forget like they forced
me to go see um independence day which i did not
want to see and i hated and then i forced them
to go see living leaving las vegas which they all
had oh wow so yeah that so leaving las vegas did
come which is surprising now that i think about
it um but it was probably not oscar nominated
that's probably why our academy award nominated
um that's probably why it came but um
so yeah it's it's that it's it's the
that thing that was unavailable to
me that sparked something and then
then i just became really interested in it and
and as a way i would say if i'm gonna sort of be
my own therapist as a way of um cementing a kind
of um iconoclasm this this desire to be different
from my peers oh they like independence day
i'm not gonna be like them i'm gonna like sex
lies and videotape that's going to be my kind
of film you know i got more and more drawn to
art cinema independent cinema and from that to
european cinema asian cinema that sort of stuff
why do you teach here at long beach city college
full-time job opened up and i got lucky um we you
know i i for six years i was an adjunct faculty
member at a bunch of different colleges and we
my wife and i lived up in west l.a and we'd
been in the same one bedroom apartment for
like eight years and we'd saved up enough
money to where we could start looking to buy
and for what we could afford
in culver city which is a
like a two-bedroom condo and uh not the
best part of culver city we could buy
a a three-bedroom house with a backyard in
long beach in a good neighborhood and so um
we bought the house in 2010 and i was
still doing the adjunct teaching and
then a job opened up here in 2011 and i got
lucky and i got it i mean it's no there's
no like i just i you know these jobs are
not um there there's not that many of them
um and so to get one that was three
miles from my house um no commute
tenure tracked i'm tenured now i just got back
from sabbatical wow congratulations yeah it's um
it's it's a it's a good thing it's a really
good thing it makes my life as a filmmaker
that much more feasible because i have
i have a real job and a regular job and
steady income and health benefits and all that
sort of stuff and so it gives me an opportunity to
go out and make stuff and not have to worry that
that it's going to kill me financially because i
have a job i have a good job um and you know i i
went to community college that's the first thing
i did before i i transferred up to san francisco
state and so um i kind of understand this world
um pretty well the um neither one of my parents
went to college my father has his um ged
and so i kind of understand coming into this
um where you might come from a family that's
you know like you're maybe gonna be the first
person from your family to graduate from college
and that sort of stuff not being able to afford
to pay for four years at a uh you need to do the
first two years at community college because
it's just too expensive to do four years at a
ucla or wherever cal state long beach um so i kind
of understand the circumstances that the students
are coming in um from because my own experience
um and and it feels really good to also make
the filmmaking world feel possible
for a group of students who
probably feel like it's not possible this is
not these are not kids that are going to sc
you're in nyu or those kinds of places and
that even though you know la's 20 miles away
it feels like another world um when you're coming
from a working class background um and your family
and your dad's not an agent or a lawyer uh yeah
and he doesn't feel like you're connected to it
and so it feels um you know it feels like you know
i'm doing something useful in the world to make it
feel um feasible for them possible um that they
could get into this field get into this industry
doesn't necessarily mean that they're going to get
to be christopher nolan or whoever because there's
lots of people who want to be christopher nolan
or wes anderson or pick whoever you want to pick
um but finding um finding a job finding
something that they like to do within the film
and television industry is absolutely possible
for them and it feels good to be able to sort of
tell them that with authority and mean it because
it is true they can so that that feels better
for me than um being someplace else with a bunch
of kids who you know they're going to be fine
they're going to be fine no matter what um if you
can afford that tuition you're going to be fine
and the connections yeah that when they get out
yeah but even even if they don't do anything in
the like you know there's all kinds of this has
got nothing to do with filmmaking but there's
all kinds of evidence that just having a degree in
the value of it it's worth like 500 000 over the
course of a career compared to a high school
diploma um just having a degree and like but
those kids that come out of one of those schools
and they come out yeah they have connections they
probably have a certain degree of wealth not all
of them they're going to be fine they're going to
be fine yes they may again they may not get to
be the next whoever but they're going to live a
nice upper middle class life live in a nice house
live in a safe environment all that sort of stuff
and trying to help these kids see that that's
possible feels more useful to me um so yeah that's
why i'm here do you see a different eagerness in
some of the community college students versus if
you've ever taught at a private school yeah i've
talked about a couple private schools a couple
private four-year schools which who both of which
had really really good students i don't want to
see i don't i don't okay that's okay that's
a bad question then no no i don't want to
my last response i don't want to make it because
i had some really good students at those schools
yeah really smart students um i can i can ask
another question no no it's not that i'm trying to
what i don't it's not that the community college
students have more eagerness what i actually see
is the opposite as i can see the way the world
weighs on them and how they feel like this is
never going to happen for me i can see how that's
that just becomes but this all feels so um out of
reach and that is um that's heartbreaking you know
to see that it's complete opposite of what you see
in a lot of those other schools where those kids
don't necessarily feel like that yeah um and so
that's again that's part of the gig that's part of
this job is like no and and also it's like we've
um sometimes when you're young and you you define
this notion of like who i'm gonna be if i'm not
quentin tarantino or you know christopher nolan
or any of those kinds of people then i haven't
made it no that's not true um and like helping
them to understand that they can make stuff um
they have the capability like teaching them how
to make stuff first of all teaching them how to
get the camera up on the sticks and how
to light a shot and all that sort of stuff
helping them understand just those tools
um and then just giving them the the um
helping them to find the agency like i can
do this i can make something if i want to
um that's i think really really crucial so that
um who the hell knows what's going to happen in
10 or 15 years with your life like no one knows
but the feeling that um if i get an idea if i
feel compelled by something if i feel something
strongly enough that i think is a film that they
can then and they know how to use the tools they
can grab the tools and try to go out and make it
they don't need anybody else's permission i
think that's a really really important thing
to to help them feel that to help them feel
that agency um making it uh making it in this
industry i don't i don't know what that i i as i
get older i have no idea what that means anymore
so yeah i don't know i don't know if that answers
the question yeah it does it actually sparks
several other questions um firstly what are
the stories that a lot of your students want
to tell here at long beach city college i mean
they vary documentary well yeah it's a lot it's
mostly narrative there are some documentary
the documentaries can be the strongest stuff
not always stuff that happens in their life stuff
that they that they find interesting stuff that's
typical of college students and then i'll have
students that are telling completely sort of out
of the blue stories like i have a student who made
a a film that is very much influenced by um third
cinema do you know what third cinema is third
cinema was a term that was um sort of created
out of a manifesto by a couple of filmmakers from
argentina and brazil like dogma but for for yeah
but south america yeah but this is in the late
60s and it's it's um highly political filmmaking
very much interested in a kind of anti-colonial
anti-imperial anti-imperialist ideology and it's
just really interesting to me that i had a student
that even knew what third cinema is it's not
something that we're teaching um you know in our
in our introductory courses so he knew what third
cinema was and so he wanted to make something that
was um sort of referenced that style as well as
bertolt brecht and jean-luc godard so the point
i'm making is i get because it is such a diverse
student body i get a wide sort of bandwidth here
of different possibilities of what the students
can be making so that's really interesting they do
come in but they come in also with less resources
we have less resources as a school than you know
some of the bigger film schools and the students
have less resources they cannot come in and go
well i've got 25 000 to make my student film
you know which some students
at some of the other schools do
um but as i constantly tell them limitations
are absolutely part of filmmaking and something
that we have to sort of get used to and start
to use like you got to use your limitations
do you think that helps with their storytelling it
can i mean i i almost think that this is like um
you're building you're building the proper muscles
for making this sort of stuff um the example i
used for them is someone like the coen brothers
who you know are making these films in this range
from 15 million dollars to 35 million dollars
and they are also talk about how they don't have
enough money in enough time right which to my
students having 15 to 35 million dollars seems
like you would have plenty of money and plenty
of time but it is the nature of the thing just
the nature of filmmaking that there's never
enough of either one of those things and so
it becomes a muscle that you need to exercise
um or that you need to build in an exercise um
because you've got to figure out okay i thought
we were going to have a full day to get this scene
we only have an hour so how are we going
to do it because that's going to happen
over and over and over again i don't care what
level you're working at that happens all the
time and so that becomes a muscle that you have
to develop like figuring out a way what is the
scene about how are we planning on shooting it how
can we simplify that and still have the thing be
what it's supposed to be um so that it makes them
better filmmakers just being able to sort of deal
with that situation because it happens all the
time um the most i call tell them constantly the
most important commodity that they have is time
and there's never enough of it so you try um you
try to get as much out of your shoot days you try
to make your shoot days as long as you possibly
can and get as much shot on your shoot days as you
can because you're not getting that time back um
so it can make their storytelling stronger
and just it makes their filmmaking better
and do most of the students come in with the idea
even if they don't totally know what they want to
be that they want to be on a level of a tarantino
or some kind of an auteur rather than they want
to be working in the industry making incredible
money like they want to sort of put their name on
something or they don't mind being part of a huge
project making a living it's both it's both and i
i like something like the class where they get to
make their their own short film that is does a lot
for self-discovery um it usually one or two one
they're going to go one or two ways they're going
to do that and and it's going to be um so exciting
even though it's so stressful that that it sort of
cements for them okay this is what i want to do i
want to have my name on things and for the other
half of them they'll go oh my god why would anyone
want to do this why would you want to go through
all this stress right you know trying to find a
diner you know nobody will let us shoot in the
diner or if they do they all want to be there and
so our dialogue is not going to work or whatever
um that they'll go i you know i want to do this
but i do not want to try to put together my own
projects let somebody put it together and
i'll come in and run the camera or whatever
yeah so it's about half and
half regarding documentaries
is observational documentary filmmaking
your favorite kind or yeah it probably is um
i don't know there's something about that
fly on the wall thing so this is i'm going
to contradict what i said earlier about
the sort of um subjective style of some
of those other filmmakers there's something
about um whether it's the the voyeurism of it
the feeling of um being able to just see
inside someone else's life um unimpeded um
that i don't know it's so exciting it's so um i
can get awestruck like um a movie like salesman
have you ever seen salesman the measles
documentary about the bible salesman oh
you should watch that film if you're interested
in documenting filmmaking you should watch them
um or even like yeah frederick weissman's um
high school um but in salesmen just watching
you just watch you watch these bible salesmen
and you watch them fail and watch them struggle
and there's no judgment there's no
commentary there's no interruption it's just
watching them watching these men struggle
in what now seems like a kind of antiquated
um job although we have telemarketing now
which is the same thing essentially um
and i don't know you get so much information
from that you learn so much without them having
to sort of um hit you over the head um with
what they're trying to get you to understand
you know i mean it's it's it's no different
than death of a salesman i mean you're getting
a kind of a very similar message with glenn gary
glenn ross you're getting a very kind of similar
message but like um there's no didacticism in it
you just watch you watch and you watch there's
a great moment in it where the guy is the main
character paul he's just gone up to somebody's
house and he wasn't able to make a sale and they
follow him back to his car and they just sit in
this car with him and he's just kind of muttering
to himself i think he starts singing a little bit
and we're just watching and do that and he's
just kind of dejected you know he's got a good
now he's got to start the car he's got to go to
the next house and try to sell the bible to them
um and it's not orchestrated it's not created
um they're just following this guy around with
their camera and their and their inaugural sound
recorder and um i don't know it feels so real and
also authentic but it also just feels so human
um they really respond to that sort of stuff
i think when you had a q a for your film uh
jonas you had another teacher in the audience
and he talked about being like in anthropology
and sometimes going up to subjects for lack of
a better word without any film in the camera
and getting them totally desensitized do you
think that's possible yeah it's possible it may
not be ethical but it's possible i mean there
is a whole school like someone like bill nichols
again talks about um ethnography and it's um you
know one of the things that happens when you're
making a documentary you're going into a place
you are just taking something from
someone you're just using their lives
to create something that you think is interesting
and that you're going to use for who knows what um
and so there is a kind of um ethical dilemma there
or an ethical question i guess you should say
um and i mean lots of people have
written about this there's been all
kinds of stuff about um the the ethics of
doing that of going especially going into
a different culture maybe a poor country
and trying to document that poverty
but there's nothing that the film is going
to do that's going to solve those people's
issues you're just kind of using their poverty
to promote yourself ultimately as a filmmaker
um so i mean that i think but that's kind of been
a thing that people have gotten more aware of um
now and so people tend to acknowledge their own
presence and perhaps how problematic some of that
is um but yeah i mean getting i will say like it's
one of the other things we talk about when we talk
about documentary film um getting people to not
be aware of the camera is very very difficult
it's you know it's the least natural thing in
the world to have a camera like pointed at you
um is one of the things not even about documentary
but trying to explain students how difficult
um the job of an actor is you know you got lights
you got a camera you got a guy holding the sound
uh the boom mic you got all
these people watching you
and somebody says be natural this is the least
natural experience of my life how can i be natural
and so it's the same thing if you're making
a documentary everybody becomes hyper aware
of the camera um you know some a friend of
mine used to say you could throw a grenade
into a room and you'll get a more natural
response than if you bring a camera into it
um and so one of the things that that i think lots
of filmmakers do is you so you don't try to hide
from that you don't try to hide from the fact
that people are aware of the camera and they're
going to interact with it um you know you let
that be part of the the movie um something like
um american movie have you ever seen an american
movie that chris smith and sarah price you know
mark borchardt he's just he's directly addressing
that camera he's performing for the camera a lot
and they just let that stuff play you know they're
not trying to be purely observational at all
um and i mean it's a movie about a guy making
a movie so it'd be kind of hard to ignore the
the technology of of a movie do you ever
plan to make another documentary again
so i know you did one on your family most
particularly on your brother yeah um i don't think
so i don't have any plans to i'm much more of a
narrative filmmaker than a documentary filmmaker
um if something were to interest i mean it's like
i said when we're talking about students like if
something sparks your interest and they want
to pick up a camera and make it then i would
um but i don't have any designs like everything
that i have planned the thing that i'm finishing
now the stuff that i have planned for the future
they're all narrative um i'm just i don't know
doc i think documentary um documentaries it's
extremely difficult and can feel like it's
never i mean they all feel like they're never
ending but there's something documentary you know
it's just it can be you know whatever hoop dreams
was i think they did that that was eight years
you know um from the time they first started
shooting those kids until the time that the
film actually premiered that may not be
right but i believe it's eight years um
it's just so time consuming but who knows but
i don't have any plans to what advice would you
have for one of your students or someone listening
who wants to make a film about their family their
environment where they grew up something that's
very close to them and the pros and cons with that
and how the people in the film eventually
see themselves whether they like it or not
and i realize i'm throwing a lot of questions
out there yeah the whole whole gamut of i mean
my advice is always if you're
interested in making something make it
um it can i mean my family was very supportive of
me doing that film it didn't it didn't bring any
sort of big issues out no big fights
um i mean you certainly don't want to
just show up with a camera and say okay
i'm making a film about our family it's
certainly something that you're gonna have
to talk through with people um i i just i
relationships and all that sort of stuff i
mean that that's i think on a case-to-case
basis i would just say generally speaking it goes
back to the thing that we talked about before
what's your point of view why are you telling
the story what's interesting about this story
there are any number of movies the
filmmakers making films about their family so
what is your point of entry um what
is the audience's point of entry
um i think that's the most important thing to talk
about um you know i mean you gotta yeah if they're
i know of multiple people who have started
making documentaries oriented around their family
and then stuff is sort of blown up within the
relationships and that was the end of the movie
and the movie didn't get finished so you got
to be careful that but i didn't go through
that experience so i don't know what the i'm
sure there are warning signs um for that thing
sort of happening i'm thinking specifically of a
filmmaker i know she was making a film about her
sister i don't even remember what the topic was
but she was around her sister and her husband and
as she's you know shooting stuff she recognizes
oh their marriage is falling apart and that was
kind of the end of the movie after that um so
you know i mean but that's a that's a case by
case you got to recognize that stuff as you're
going in um but i i i always go back to like
why are you telling the story what's
what's your point of view why is it unique
what's different about it um because they're i
mean as cameras get easier and easier to get a
hold of they get cheaper um we can shoot
on our phone everybody's making a movie
why does anybody need to see yours um what's
your point of view now here's the other side of
that though i would say this doesn't matter
um even if you're a movie to some degree
or another it doesn't matter if you really
feel compelled to make it you should make it
even if it's the same as 10 other movies
you should make it or 100 other movies
because the um regret of not making
it is way worse than the feeling of oh
they made that movie's my movie's just like their
movie that doesn't feel great but i should have
made that feels way worse way worse um but if you
want your movie to stand out you got to figure out
your perspective and point of view you may have
touched on this earlier but i was hoping we could
just go over again the modes of documentary film
okay so well these are not my modes these are bill
nichols modes uh so there is expository um the
observational mode which is sort of completely
quote unquote objective where you stand back and
you don't interfere there's a participatory mode
which is the mode where the filmmakers interact so
someone like michael moore would be making sort of
participatory documentaries there's self-reflexive
mode which is um films that are essentially about
their own making so there's a very famous
um soviet film from like 1920 called the man
with the movie camera it's like 1920 something
like that in the man with a movie camera you watch
the cameraman shoot the film that you're watching
you watch the editor edit the film that you're
watching you watch an audience watch the film that
you're watching it's a film that's um sort of only
um the only truth it can offer is that well it
knows it's a movie so here's this is the truth
that i'm giving you um it's very self-reflexive
uh there's poetic there's a poetic mode so that's
like the godfrey reggio films uh koianna
scotsie those films um they're very lyrical
am i forgetting something i feel like i'm
forgetting something five observational
participatory self-reflexive uh poetic then
there's um the performative which is the
grizzly man and um thin blue lines sort of um and
something like stories we tell and then expository
so six i think that's right so then cinema verite
cinema verite would be like participatory story
yeah because some of it there's a difference i'm
gonna get very pedantic but there's a difference
between cinema verite and direct cinema direct
cinema is purely observational it's frederick
weissman it's no interaction whatsoever and cinema
verite there's lots of handheld camera and they're
out on the street but there will be interaction
there will be something like american movie or
the films or roger and me the michael moore film
so you brought up werner herzog and errol morris
and so i'm thinking like the thin blue line or
into the abyss where you have multiple points of
view and i think i got this from something you
said truth doesn't exist it's only perception
which is excellent yeah i like that make a t-shirt
out of it yeah especially in this day and age
twitter and all that so talk about uh documentary
filmmaking and perception so really is it just
perception we're going after because since truth
is so there's so many truths everyone's reality
is different yeah i mean i don't i don't know if
we're going after anything i mean i i i think that
filmmakers who are more attuned to that idea
um will probably make more interesting work um
oh boy i don't i'm an opinionated guy so
i'm trying not to um i i like there's just
i'm trying to say something about this
filmmaker is not very good but this filmmaker
is um i i there's there's there's just
there's something about understanding that um
trying to present something as an absolute um
perhaps yeah maybe it's this day and age or
but perhaps is not the best way to sort of
get at any kind of truth if you're trying
to present sort of an absolute thing um because
it's maybe an argument it's not even an argument
um i don't know maybe we're just beyond
that as a culture i don't know if we need it
um there's an argument to be made that we
absolutely need it when when you have um someone
in the most powerful position in the world who
just is gaslighting constantly and everyone
around him is gaslighting constantly and so
we need some sort of standard of truth right
um but within a if we're thinking about in
terms of a film i don't know it sometimes it
feels like it's it's lacking um because it's
so absolute i'm trying to think of an example
where i where it shows how problematic it
is and right now and but i don't want to
right well if you think about let's say into the
abyss herzog is showing multiple points of view
of what happened that night you know or thin blue
line same thing what happened that night everybody
had their own thing even west of memphis you know
different different things and so to me that's
terribly interesting because everybody was showing
a different version of their own reality yeah
what's interesting i guess about it too is
that so especially someone like aaron morris
is he is but i he's figured out he's you
know the whole point of the same blue line um
is he's figured out the truth right he's
letting us know that like okay we're getting
these different perspectives and i'm going to
show you sort of these reenactments where we
get those different perspectives sort of played
out but then he leaves us with that audio tape of
whatever the guy's name essentially confessing
to the crime right um and so there's a kind of
ultimate authority that he's taken up with that
where like i found the truth like i was showing
you all these variations of the truth but here's
what really happened and this guy just admitted to
it um so there's a kind of authority or power that
he's taking as the ultimate truth-teller which is
kind of interesting um and part of it
coming from i think his background as a
as a private investigator he's you know
they think of that movie as an investigation
the way he's reenacting he's doing his reenactment
so he can see if that sort of holds truth in his
investigation um yeah i don't know i mean when
i think about stories we tell and and she's
she's not coming to any conclusions she's
trying to figure out what this family history is
and um but she's not you know there's a whole
challenge that happens have you seen that film
i haven't it sounds good there's a whole challenge
that happens with her and somebody else involved
in her with her family and where he questions why
she has the right to tell this story or this part
of the story he has the he should be telling that
part of the story it's a really fascinating thing
because kind of like what we were just talking
about earlier when i was talking about bias
there is something about when you pick
up the camera and say i have the right
to do this there might be a whole bunch of
other people who stand up and say no you don't
you don't have the right to do this
um so i don't know hey i don't if it's
what somebody should or should not do i guess
i'm sure i can think of a you know march of the
penguins that's a fun film that's completely
expository you know there's nothing wrong with
that necessarily um so they're it's not that
there's no value in that sort of stuff i just
always find the other films more interesting i
guess do you ever recommend people storyboard
for documentary film if they're going to do um
like reenactments i would um you know just because
to design those you got to design those just like
you would a narrative film um i mean if if what
they're going to do like if they're considering
um a really sort of um complex sequence uh
the the editing sequence that they're considering
then i would storyboard it like okay how is
trying to figure out how this is going to cut
together right um the reason you storyboard like
does this stuff fit um so if they were planning
on doing something where they weren't sure
then yes i would but it's not something that i
make my students do who are making documentaries
because they have so much to do in terms of
preparation getting questions ready all that
sort of stuff getting all their permission and
they're gonna spend so much more time trying to
cut theirs together um you know they they don't
have the um the luxury of having a script and
then a storyboard and because they don't
know what they're going to get necessarily
um you know it might be i know i know of
documentary filmmakers who do it after
they've shot right they've shot all they got all
their footage and they're trying to sort of as
they're putting together some sort of audiovisual
script and then they might storyboard a sequence
to look at it to see this is going to cut
this to this to this that kind of idea
so just depend what they're doing that was
actually was going to ask you next is then
once they have an audio track and then working
off that is sort of their script and then piecing
together the visuals from there i mean is that
how yeah you know one of the best things this is
not mine this is a friend of mine mary trunk
uh who's a documentary filmmaker she's great
she made this film a family documentary called the
watershed um 10 or 15 years ago whenever it was
um and she talked about how she
edited it um like it was a radio show
um and so she would not even she would completely
ignore what was happening in the visuals and just
sort of piece it together based upon what she was
listening to the sequence that made sense to her
orally and then go back and sort of stitch
together the video keeping that construction
of the audio first i mean you know i know
documentary editors who will not work and
rightfully so will not work until you have
that script written because it's just too um
it's just too much material you can't put it
together without it you know once you have that
thing stitched together then you can make choices
about rearranging and all that sort of stuff
do you think filmmakers want their viewers
to feel they're in a moral position
like a higher viewing ground when they're
watching their documentary or no that's just
something i'm predicting some of them some of them
might um i mean it depends upon the film you know
i'm i'm more interested in films that don't
judge their characters or their subjects um
but some of them might want
you to be in this sort of um
taking a kind of moral authority i mean it just
depends upon the movie i don't know it depends
upon the subject matter what they're doing i'm
sure i mean there are multiple examples i mean
speaking of sort of moral authorities from someone
like michael moore takes a kind of moral authority
um in most of his movies um and wants his
audience to align with him in that authority
um but i don't know it depends upon what they're
doing all right if we look at gray gardens
i don't think that was really put out there it
was more just no the measles yeah the i mean
the measles are that's i mean one of the same
guys we made salesmen um i think that's one of the
reasons that they're so celebrated is that their
ability to get into these very intimate personal
places and experiences and we get to see these
things that maybe we shouldn't be able to see but
we get to see these things and we see them without
judgment we see them without the you know those
they don't condescend they don't condescend
to the bible salesman they're working in
florida they don't condescend to those
women in great gardens um they are
trying to give us some kind of portrait
of humanity that's what makes them so good
um so interesting um so but i i also don't
i don't for me to take an authority to say
what filmmaker should or shouldn't do i don't
think it's right either you know i think you
can make a film an interesting film any number
of ways and so there might be a way for someone
um there are ways for people to do that you
know i like roger and me and michael moore
film and he's he's standing above his
subjects for the most part you know
um so yeah there's lots of interesting
there's lots of ways to do interesting stuff
i jokingly said that i'm bringing up old
examples of films do you think documentary
filmmaking has changed especially with reality
tv and especially with the culture of being
so sped up yeah i mean in the way that in that
way all in narrative filmmaking and documentary
filmmaking have changed they're both much faster
than they once were and i mean also in the same
way they're much more feasible for anybody right
anybody can you can shoot stuff very cheaply
right and that makes a lot of sense um it helps a
lot when you're making a documentary film now when
you're rolling that camera you don't have to worry
about all the film that's burning through right
with each one of those um each minute cost you so
many hundred dollars of film stock and and um um
development um now you don't have to
worry about it just pop the card in
and just keep going um so it's changed that way
and that allows you to shoot more so maybe it's
harder to edit and all that sort of stuff um has
it gotten fat i mean the culture's gotten faster
like the culture is just faster um and so
in the way we consume things is faster and
um you know like the idea that the measles had
no idea when they made salesmen in 1960 that
somebody could watch it on their phone right that
was not even they had just gotten these cameras
now that they could take out of the studio
and start following people around and these
these kind of handheld devices that
wasn't feasible 10 years before
so yeah of course it's changed and of course
the documentary has changed because of that
is it better or worse i don't know i don't
like to make those moral judgments like
i was talking about this was somebody else oh
when i was doing color i don't hear the other
day we were talking and you know like my students
now they're used to um they shoot stuff they
edit it and they put it up on youtube and it
all happens in like a day you know they grab
their phone they go out and shoot something
they don't really plan it out they just see what
they're doing and so one of the things that i'm
doing is sort of training them i'm trying to break
down that process so now that they're planning
more like that their idea they fully form an idea
you know they write a script in other words and
they plan it out in pre-production they take their
time with it they shoot over multiple days you
know full days of shooting all that sort of stuff
but there's nothing wrong with the
way they were doing it for their
youtube you know videos right there's that
process like that's a really important part of
their um learning they're learning how to shoot
stuff they're learning how to edit stuff they're
learning how what they're interested in and
it's really fast and it's consumed really fast
and it's forgotten about you know just as fast
um but i you know i like it i don't want to pass
judgment on that whether that's good or bad
because i don't know i don't think i don't
think it's either um but it's just the way it is
right and they're they're used to it and so um
i don't know it's like documentary for
a while there in the early early aughts
it was the thing that it was um there
was this kind of box off explosion box
office explosion with like fahrenheit 911
a few other movies march of the penguins
um searching for sugar man yeah thank you
for sure that's right yeah that's great um
but now man it's hard and it's hard for
them to exist in the box office space um
so i don't know what that means
for their style um you know
trying to think what's the last doc that i saw
that wasn't like a true crime thing that was on
um you know netflix or whatever i'm trying
to think of the last feature film doc that i
saw in the last two three years i know there's
been some stuff but i can't even think about it
um well hbo did um the inventor about uh the
theranose founder oh yeah i didn't see that
so good i didn't see that um nor if i wasn't
there somebody wrote a book about it right
two didn't they maybe that i don't know but it's
elizabeth elizabeth holmes right yeah yeah so
i mean it seems like some of that is coming back
more into the mainstream into the art house cinema
but you're right in terms of just the the main you
know i won't mention the name of the theaters but
yeah these mainstream theaters that don't show
sort of art house cinema i don't see a lot yeah
well it's just man it's just so i mean documentary
anything it's so hard to get people to see your
movie it is so hard because there is so much
stuff you know um i i went to see the souvenir
yesterday which i loved it's such a good
movie it's so well crafted and well made
well act the acting is unbelievable and then
i stupidly looked up like box office stuff
which i never do but i was just curious because
here's this movie she's a british filmmaker
tilda swinton's in it but she's not the lead it's
her daughter who's the lead who's not known at all
and the the guy who's playing her boyfriend
he's a great actor but he's not known in the
states you know and here 824 has yeah and they've
spent a decent chunk of money promoting the movie
and so he's like okay well let me see i wonder if
they're doing i mean it's not doing well at all
it's less than a million dollars in box office
and i imagine they've spent you know and that's
that's at least a three million dollar movie it
might be a five to seven million dollar movie and
they've spent that much or more on on marketing
um i'd have to think and how they're going to
make that money back so it just and this is not a
criticism i'm glad that they put that movie out i
want that movie to be in the world i want to have
it find its audience and all that sort of stuff
but you go oh my god they're going to lose
money on this movie and that that's bad for
the cult that's bad for the film world it's bad
for because 8 24 is putting out interesting stuff
and so i want them to do well and so when they
and especially with that kind of movie and uh
sorry if i'm this is going to ruin so i want them
to do well um so i mean it's not just documentary
film it's narrative film it's um as i saw some
the depressive thing depressing thing about um
paul schrader's last film first reform you know
i mean that's a movie that was made for i think
around three million dollars an a24 bought it for
500 000 um so there's all this um there's all this
that creates downward pressure when you're trying
to make a movie you know we we have a budget for
three million dollars well paul schrader's movie
oscar nominated movie with the master of the
american cinema it's a great lead actor who's
known cost three million dollars and they only
sold it for five hundred thousand dollars so you
need to make your movie for five hundred thousand
dollars and if it doesn't have and you're not paul
schrader and you don't have ethan hawk you have a
you have a known actor but a lesser known actor
so actually you need to make it for 250 000 and so
there's all this downward pressure on the people
producing movies because the um the audiences now
i imagine they've made their money back at this
point got once they got the oscar nominations and
all that sort of stuff i'm just i'm sure they've
made the the rest of the budget back um but that's
a it's a really really difficult time um to try to
make try to make anything that's not 30 million or
more or less than a hundred thousand dollars um
anything from 100 000 to 29 million is really
really hard to get made um because it's very hard
for the people who are going to fund it to see how
they're going to get their money back and that's
no different than in documentary film but it is
easier to make a documentary film for less than
a hundred thousand dollars than it is a narrative
i know you have a lot of students that'll probably
come in that maybe they have no idea what they
want to do and that's totally natural you can be
in your 40s and 50s and not know what you want
to do but how does that translate into the films
that they make if they're sort of this ambiguous
question of what are they going to do with the
rest of their lives where do they fit into this
you know working world whatever how does that
translate into the films that they make here the
films that they make here um well that probably
means that they don't know how to like if they're
not sure um then they'll probably go into the film
not sure and so there won't be anything specific
about it i mean i would say one of the things that
um that students um struggle with the most not
just in their filmmaking but kind of everything
and what they write their analytical papers is
everything feels very generic it feels very broad
it feels very borrowed and so the thing that they
but that comes with youth um but the thing that
they have to sort of work on and getting used
to is getting specific getting specific in
terms of their ideas like what do you want
this to really be about getting specific if we're
talking about in terms of a film a narrative film
getting specific about what your character does
what do they do what are they doing in a scene
um what is the scene about how specific can
you get um so i i would say that that sort of
directionlessness i don't like calling it that
because that that feels a little judgmental but
just a sense of not knowing if they're not
sure they will be unsure in making you know um
once somebody figures out that that's what
they're interested in that's what they want
to do they will get more confident and more
sure about what they're trying to express
too and they will get more specific in their
the content i always think it's such a gift
to know what you want to do when you're like
16 17 yeah yeah it is i was i mean i did but
i don't think i was 70. i was probably i was
probably 18. hey you know i've been like um
but i also didn't know anything about it like i
didn't grow up with a camera in my hand i was not
a photographer and i was like i said before like
there's no film culture i didn't have i don't know
anything about filmmaking it's actually a story
i tell my students that are feeling intimidated
or feel like they don't belong or whatever because
that was me when i was at um san francisco state
i always tell that story like they the first
production class that they used to make you take
because there's so many students they can't put
you all in production right away but they call
it a production class and it was a large lecture
class of i don't know 100 students 125 students
whatever and you never touch a camera in the
production class you just get lectured too and
the first day the instructor says something like
uh and a film camera standard speed is and it felt
like the other 99 students all said 24 frames
a second i didn't know i didn't know anything
about film production or you know standard camera
speed or anything like that sync sound so i there
was this feeling of like oh my god i am completely
um i'm out of my depth everybody else here knows
more than i do there's no way i'm going to be
able to catch up i don't know anything about film
production i don't know anything about cameras
i don't know anything about this technology
can i actually do this so it's a story i tell
my students because you know i mean it's not
like it came to me and i'm still learning i'm
still learning about technology but it's a story
i tell my students just to know that like you're
absolutely not the only person who's ever sat down
in a film class and not known all of this stuff
or understood it and you can come in as a complete
layman um but that doesn't mean that you can't be
interested in film and ultimately sort of become a
filmmaker that is just that's just learning that's
just picking up the gear and learning the gear
um that takes time but it's not like some
impossible mountain that you can't climb
um so i think that's like that's like a crucial
thing you know this is sort of answering a
question that we had in one of the other segments
um especially for this population of students um
because like again the equipment can feel like
it's from another world because if i tell them you
know that that 5d costs a couple thousand dollars
they don't have a couple thousand dollars to throw
down on a 5d um or you know they get to use in our
more advanced classes they get to use a canon c300
which is a ten thousand dollar camera without any
lenses on it's a ten thousand dollar camera and so
that can be you know and it is the difference
between those students and students at uh like
a four-year private university okay cool you
know let me get my hands on it great you know um
so um i don't know how i got them i'm off on a
tangent no no i like it oh sorry so when you were
at san francisco state did you then eventually
feel like okay i have my own way into this it
doesn't have to be like everybody else and i'm
okay with that i mean yeah that you know san
francisco is just culturally it's just different
than los angeles and i mean that's a very um
independence not even the right
word it's a very gorilla style
like there's not that that's the school that's
that's geared more towards the avant-garde
and documentary there's some narrative
filmmakers i was a narrative filmmaker
my mentor there she's in there and she's still
there she's a narrative filmmaker um but um
i never felt like i was um ostracized or outside
i just felt like i didn't know enough and when i
got out of there i still didn't feel like i knew
enough that's why i went to grad school that was
one of the main reasons i went to grad school i
mean i got to make um a couple films one really
this first one doesn't really count i got to make
one film and and i you know i directed a film but
i realized while i'm doing i don't know what i'm
doing and you know and you shouldn't so but that
was and i don't know enough about the equipment
i don't know enough about the technology i
and i knew i actually wanted to teach i knew
that that was the way i was going to try to um
make a living i mean i knew a few
things i knew i wanted to make my own
films the only thing i was interested is in was
making my own stuff um and i knew that i wasn't
going to fall out of school and be able to make a
living doing that so i had to figure out a way to
to do that to try to make my own stuff and
still be able to pay the rent and i'm too
um egotistical to do it as an assistant editor
on like reality television or something i just
there's just people who can do that are just
they're better people than me because i just
couldn't i could not do it so i figured i was
going to teach so i need to learn more so i can
you know claim to have the authority
to be able to teach a class
and i just need to learn where i need
to make more films so then i went to
grad school so when i got out of there i felt
better but i still knew i needed to learn more and
i still need to learn more like you continually
learning every time you do it every single time
eli how did you know that you were a filmmaker and
not a film watcher that's a really good question
so that was kind of like the thing that i was
going through at san francisco state maybe i don't
know enough about this technology maybe i should
just maybe i should go on and get a phd like that
was something that i would seriously considering
um but for whatever i don't know how you know
other than you keep having the um the drive
to make something i think that's probably the
the test like one of the things i tell the
students you know they they kind of don't
know what they're getting themselves into the
first time they make even just a short film
and so when it's all over and they're stressed
out and they feel like their movie's not as
good as it could have been or it's not what
they wanted to make because it's a movie um and
i tell them that that's
the test the test is though
you went through all that stress it was
incredibly hectic you're ultimately feel like
the film could be better which is what
everybody thinks after they make a movie
so you're not 100 happy with the finished product
but the test is if you wake up in a couple days or
a couple weeks in a couple months or a couple
months and you want to make something again
then you want to be a filmmaker you know
um and so the the drive to like oh i
i'm interested in this i'm interested in using the
camera to try to get at ideas or tell stories or
project some perspective of the world um if
that doesn't go away and it hasn't gone away yet
um that's that's how i knew but i mean
it was there was a question that was you
know in those moments like i was describing
where oh my god they all know more than i do
and there's something about just filmmaking um
because it's so heavily tilted towards men or
guys and they are so full of canby not all guys
can be so full of bravado and trying to prove
themselves um film sets are so full of guys
trying to prove how much they know what
they've done and um so that can be really
intimidating like that oh i don't know as much
as these guys are talking about a lens that i
don't know anything about they're talking about
something with a camera they're talking about
something with a dolly shot that i don't know
anything about um and so that can make you go
okay this is not i'll just be the guy who maybe
i'll write reviews or whatever or i'll i'll write
a do a dissertation on mike lee films because i
love mike lee or whatever um and um but then the
oh this is an idea i mean i should write that down
you know you start writing something the great
thing about um you know if you if you are a um
like me i consider myself like a writer director i
write my own stuff and i and i make it nobody can
stop me there's nothing stopping me from writing a
script there's nothing styled like that doesn't
cost any money it's just my time and if i'm um
i'm enjoying it and i feel like it's interesting
and it can turn into something then i can just
do that and then i can make the decision whether
or not i want to try to make it you know um that
i don't know that's still that still holds a
lot of pleasure for me if it stops if it's not
it's not pleasurable anymore i'll stop doing it
because filmmaking is too hard filming is way
too hard to do something that's not like you're
not getting anything out of it it doesn't feel
it's not fun it doesn't feel like um you're
doing anything interesting you know you have
a film about religion that you wrote and direct
but you say it's not faith-based yeah it's not a
faith-based film but it's a film about religion
yeah um i guess religion is a subject matter
but um faith-based means to me that um that it's a
movie it would be a movie that's trying to get the
audience to believe in this specific um religious
doctrine because that's what most face pa most
faith-based films do um and so it's not that
it's it's it's not a film that's not trying to
um proselytize at all um you know i grew up i
grew up in that world i grew up an evangelical
christian and so naturally it's something
that i find interesting um and i could um
tell a specific story about it i thought so
that's why i got interested or decided to make it
and how has it been to or you had the
film hasn't been released yet right no
no yeah we're not finished yet okay not finishing
almost almost i'm i'm in the midst of color and
sound design and all that sort of stuff but
we're almost there when you were creating the
protagonist for the film did you start with a
problem or a dilemma that needed to be solved
yeah i guess i did i mean i i knew
i wanted to make a film in the world
and i knew i wanted to design it around a
scenario where a character who is devout
um goes through a crisis a character
who's only seen or understood the world
in one way is then put into a situation
where it kind of blows up their world view
i knew that was it the circumstances of how
we got there or what place they were put in
um i didn't know but i knew that's the situation
that i wanted i knew what the character was like
and what kind of situation i wanted to put
them in or what kind of how i want to change
their context i guess how long did it take you to
write the script i wrote the first script of the
first draft of the script 10 years ago wow so this
idea it's called faith right was that the original
title okay had been probably swirling around you
all your life maybe yeah i mean well yeah when
you grow up grow up that way i mean it's going to
inform your um your outlook and certainly inform
what you think of as could be interesting
narrative material and i had finished the
the documentary and done the festival thing
with it and um but knew i was like i want to do
um i want to do narrative so i sat down and i
had a couple other scripts but neither one of
them were either good and he could and i want to
write something new and so i sat down and wrote
something new um and that's what came out and then
it was a process of okay that's the first draft of
the script i wrote a couple more drafts of the
script over the next year or year and a half
and um how am i going to try to make it and
so what i did which i still recommend to
people is recommended students what i did
was i just started looking for producers
who worked in the independent art space you
know they made like already american movies
cheaply um not things that you know i wasn't
sending to people who were making 15 million
dollar movies i'm making i'm standing in the
people who are making movies for 2 million or less
and to see if it not just that but also films that
i liked films that i responded to the idea being
if i'm going to get the money to to make this i
need to make it cheaply enough because it would be
my first feature and also i you you don't want to
bark up spend your time barking up the wrong tree
right i'm not going to send it to people who
are making low-budget thrillers or low-budget
horror films because it's just not like nothing
wrong with those kinds of films this is not my
avenue um and so i sent it to lots
of people mostly you get ignored
um that's kind of the nature of the
thing most time people just don't respond
some nice not for us rejections and
then mike ryan is a producer out in
new york and i sent it to him specifically because
he had produced two movies one called junebug
with amy adams that i just loved um well two
movies that i love junebug and then another movie
kelly reichert's second movie old joy he was a
producer on both of those films and i loved them
and they were in the same style that i wanted to
make this film in and he responded to the material
so um but then off we went but from that period
it was still another six years or so before we
actually started to make the movie it just takes
that long we wrote more drafts got into some
this thing out in new york where we got some
money people to read it and sony pictures classics
but it still took forever finally we were able
to do it was that the whole 10-year journey or
was there times when you weren't sure that this
was a topic you want to explore are you always
no i'm stubborn all hell so when i said this is
a movie i said this is maybe you know i i like um
i don't know there's uh maybe this is complete
arrogance um but uh i feel like i understand
what makes a movie and so um that i would
be interested in i guess then you know some
other people may not think it's a movie but
for me i was like this this is a movie and
so um i was gonna stick to it until i got it
made now there were certainly plenty of times
where i was like oh this is never gonna happen i
don't know how this is ever gonna come together
um but um yeah i wasn't i wasn't gonna stop you
know um i think that that's like when you are
in the low budget space and you don't have access
to all kinds of money or connections or whatever
um you don't have an agency that's backing you
that's gonna you know find the money for you um
the one thing you have is your like your
perseverance or your stubbornness because
nobody else your sisyphus is pushing the rock
up the hill and nobody's to push it up with you
so you're just going to keep doing it and it's
going to roll back over on you a bunch of times
um but that's that's the one commodity that i
could bring that would be the thing that would um
ensure that the movie's gonna get made
i couldn't bring the money i couldn't
bring all the connections i couldn't bring
any of that stuff but i could bring that
like i was just gonna keep pushing the rock um
so yeah and then we ultimately were able to do
it we were ultimately able to put the money
together and find some actors and shoot the
film and brian garrity plays the protagonist
yeah brian plays his protagonist brian is um
brian's an extraordinary actor he's an
extraordinary actor it was um i've worked
with i've worked with good actors before he's
the best actor i've ever worked with it was uh
it was kind of an amazing thing to watch because
he's a very the character is the character's
going through really rough time and it's a very
quiet film it's a very and he has to be so so
subtle but in that subtlety showing a lot of pain
they're exhibiting a lot of pain and um and brian
is funny and he's gregarious and he's talkative
and he's jokes and he's a lot of fun on set and
to watch somebody who can switch from that from
joking around and playing and having a lot of
fun to all of a sudden he's in this moment with a
character who's having to go through some grief a
bunch of grief it's an extraordinary thing to
watch it's like the greatest gift to just be
able to point your camera at somebody who can do
that and do it so well it was it was extraordinary
so you're in the editing phases of it yeah the
picture's locked but so we're in color and sound
and everything yeah we're done cutting so 10 years
10 years yeah yeah but it's not an uncommon story
you know there's all kinds of people who
have that story if it took me you know seven
eight nine ten years to finally get a movie
made i mean it was going on a long time and
and um you know at one point you know i
realized from the documentary until i don't know
i was probably a couple years into my relationship
with mike as we're you know rewriting the film and
and but i'm still feeling like are we going
to be able to make this and i look up and go
wow i haven't made anything i haven't made
anything it had been i don't know four or
five years that i hadn't you know actually
directed i'd just written stuff you know
and so then i just started making shorts again
like i have to keep learning like to keep trying
to become a better filmmaker if i'm gonna
make a feature film i need to make more films
um and so i made uh i made a series of shorts over
the course of three years and that was really um
it was really great for me it's like get back into
the um get back into the habit of making stuff and
um get better at it um i i think you know you ask
this question about your film watcher or filmmaker
one of the things that i think that for me
um makes me want to keep doing it is it feels
like a nut that i could never quite crack is it
so there's so much to do it's so hard to make
to make something that's really
good that really flies it's a i'm
never going to quite get this right and so you're
just i'm just going to keep trying to get it right
um and so doing it over and over
again you know just in short form like
i remember somebody said that too oh i'm done with
short films when i was younger somebody said that
to me i'm done with short films i'm going onto
a feature and i thought well yeah that's true
we should you should just move on you should
graduate and now like no like just whatever you
can make if you can just make youtube videos make
youtube videos because you'll learn doing that
um you know after we finish this thing you know
i've got a couple of other um bigger things that
i'd like to do but then it's not well maybe they
would happen right away but i kind of doubt it um
and if they don't i'll set up a couple of shorts
and make some more shorts you know because it'll
i'll keep learning by making um that's kind of the
crucial thing that i figured out while i was doing
that your producer for faith has been with you for
how long seven years is that is it going on eight
for a producer to stay that's pretty committed
yeah yeah i think so i mean i think for the life
of a producer you know it's it's different than
than being a director and that they've got to
have so many balls in the air um you know they
can have 15 projects all in various states and
only a couple of them are going to go you know
and so for for him i mean i think that the um
you know the the first couple years is just about
rewriting it and then trying to get some awareness
for the script um and then from that trying to
find cast and raise money i mean but that's a
couple years process as well it's funny i just
saw brian i don't know a couple months ago for
um adr and he was talking about a small pride
another small project he's trying to do but he's
like yeah four years it'll take four years to get
all the money together or whatever it's just this
is not that much money this is i'm gonna be a
downer it's just not this much that much money
out in the in the independent film space you know
especially for indie dramas which is what mike
produces and what i'm interested in making these
kind of art arty dramas um and so it's you're
you're you're competing with a lot of people
for a very little very very little pie
piece of the pie um and so it just it takes
time but yeah he held on he held on he really
believed in the project so i'm i'm very grateful
to him for that you know and and because of his
name because he's known i mean you know
junebug i think at the time was the was
the lowest budget movie to ever get nominated
for an oscar because amy adams got nominated
for that movie um you know and his his films have
played you know everywhere venice sundance toronto
um and they've been nominated for independent
spirit awards and all that sort of stuff so his
name being attached to the project it's like that
that's was very valuable going forward um so yeah
do you share with your students the process and
how long it took oh yeah are they surprised yeah
no i'm uh they know me for being uh a realist like
there's there's no like uh there's not like stars
in our eyes kind of kid this kind of thing
it's like all right kids this is the reality
this was 10 years and it was still hard to raise
the money and i mean and i talked some of the some
of the stuff we were talking about in terms of
numbers you know i was talking to them about like
the films that for instance have played sundance
that are going to be made for or made for anywhere
from a million to five million dollars and they're
mostly getting if they get an offer lots of them
don't even get offers but they get an offer
they're 100 to 150 000 for for worldwide rights
you know and so um it just to be i'm trying to
be very realistic with them so they understand
um but um if you really want to do it you'll still
do it it's it's i'm a very practical guy and so
one of the things we talk about quite a bit the
way i've set my life up is i have this one thing
that pays my bills so i can do this other thing
um and so if you can figure out a way it doesn't
have to be teaching and matter of fact i
wouldn't recommend teaching because there's
fewer and fewer of these jobs out there but if
you can figure out a thing that you don't hate
you don't have to love it but you don't
hate it and it pays well enough to where
you know you can pay your bills pay
your rent pay your mortgage whatever
if you have kids they got new shoes on their
feet and then you can sort of carve out time
to do this other thing whether it's directing
your own features or shooting you know you want
to be lots of students want to be dp i would say
that's probably more popular than even directing
oh wow um i like the gear they like the camera
they wanna they wanna play with the play with
the tools the toys um that's kind of what i
talk to them about is is facing that reality
because how many kids are in film school all
around the country are all around the world who
all want to do the same thing um and so you've
got to figure out how you're going to survive
first and then you can sort of navigate
your way into that whatever you whatever
avenue you want to go whether it's writing
directing screenwriting dp editing whatever
do a lot of the students say well so and so put
their first movie on a credit card or whatever so
they you know what i i at other schools they
probably do here it's not a thing i mean yeah
like well we i come out of the generation of of
you know kevin smith like kevin smith does this
thing with clerks and it's all credit cards
and and then his career sort of blows up so
there were a lot i never did that but there were
a lot of people of my generation who did do that
you know and to not as much success as as
they just had a lot of debt uh and not a
huge blossoming career um so no they i don't hear
that much i mean i will say that i give them the
the like um if i was a film student now um
what um what i would probably do is i would um
i don't know if i would form a company
but you know find two other people
who are different than me so if i'm the writer
director i'd find somebody who's really good with
a camera and maybe somebody who's good at post
or somebody who's good as a kind of producer he
doesn't mind calling people out of the blue and
asking for stuff for free somebody like that and
form our own little group or whatever and
decide you know we want to do three to five
things over the next year to two years whether
they be three short films or a short film in
two commercials or some music videos or whatever
and figure out how much that's going to cost um
how much i shouldn't even say how much
can it cost how much can you put together
so can all three of you save a hundred bucks a
month so if all three of you are saving a hundred
bucks a month now all of a sudden you got about
almost four thousand dollars you get about 3 600
of each one of you puts together 100 puts puts
away 100 bucks a month and can all three of you
put a thousand dollars on a credit card thousand
dollars in debt it's not horrible so if they all
three of them could put a thousand dollars on a
credit card without killing themselves now all of
a sudden you got almost seven thousand dollars
then can all three of you start a crowdfunding
campaign where you raise twenty five hundred
dollars so with that you got about ten grand
they're close to it what can you do for ten
thousand dollars you know the three of you can
you guys come up with again three ideas five ideas
all of them have to be small i would not recommend
that they make a feature film i know those people
who make feature films for ten thousand dollars
maybe if it's your third or fourth movie i would
not do it for my first but some people could
do i'm not i can i cannot do it i could not make
anything that is any good for ten thousand dollar
feature film for ten thousand dollars i don't what
chloe zao did with the writer for fifty thousand
dollars to me is amazing did you see the writer no
i wanted to beautiful movie it's all the trailers
fifty thousand it's unbelievable but so
anyway that that like that is a plan where
they're not going hugely in debt there's a
little bit of debt and if they can't do the
debt then they don't do the debt you just do the
savings and the crowdfunding and then you get
six grand or something like that right okay
what can we do for six thousand dollars
um and it allows them to make stuff they don't
need anybody's permission it's just the three
of them or the four of them they're doing the
stuff that they're interested in they're getting
better at it and maybe one of those things gets
them a little attention to do something bigger
probably not a film for marvel but maybe a local
commercial for somebody who has a little bigger
budget and they can do something more or a bigger
music video or a bigger short film or whatever
some sort of branded content for somebody um that
would be the process that i would go through if i
was a student now coming out and i this is
by the way none of this is there are people
who are doing this all over the place now so
i'm not this is not some uh panda padded pant
i have no patent on this patented idea
um but it's a smart way to go about it
without weight because what most of us
do when we get out of film school is we
all right i'm just gonna wait for somebody to call
me and offer me all kinds of money to do something
and that never happens alexander payne is like the
only person i know that that happened for because
everybody loved his graduate thesis film is there
any way you could have green lit faith any earlier
probably not no maybe because it's there's
um well yeah if i made it for less money if
we made the movie for ten thousand dollars
sure but i couldn't have made the movie um
you know like um i think there's there's
some people well yeah what'd i say
i i had a friend of mine say that to me at
one point probably three or four years ago
why don't you just you know try to do it now
for fifty thousand dollars or something like
that which i didn't i don't couldn't have put
together 50 000 even if i wanted to at that time
um but i had said well i want to give it its
best chance um you know to make it at a level
where um it has a better chance of sort of getting
out into the world and people seeing it and
responding to it now that still may not happen and
um since we didn't make it for we made it for more
than fifty thousand dollars but not a ton more
well a little bit more but anyway um so i mean
i could always green let it green light it myself
if i was gonna make it for super super cheap um
but i needed some outside money in order
to make it at a level and we still had
to make it at a smaller level than originally
intended you know we were supposed to shoot in
may of last year and the money fell out you know
to make it at a certain level and the money fell
out two weeks before we were supposed to shoot
again this is not an uncommon story this happens
to so many people um even much bigger films
than ours which it was a devastating thing
but after i got over that we sort of picked
ourselves up and i had to rewrite the film to
be smaller so that we could make it a level that
we knew we could get that amount of money for
um and so that's what we did you know you
were asking about limitations i mean there's
a limitation right there we had a movie that
was budgeted needed to be made at this level
we couldn't get that money at that level we
could get the money at this level so then
we wrote a movie that or i rewrote the movie so
it fit that budget level and to do it for fifty
thousand dollars it would have been a different
level i mean the cost of making a movie just um
the labor alone you know what what it means when
you're getting in those budget levels at 50 000 or
you know eliza hitman's first film it felt like
love which i think she made for like 20 grand
or something like that it's a beautiful movie
just like one of those things like the writer
both of them are getting bigger budgets and they
deserve them because to be able to do what they
did with the limited amount of money they both
deserve they both deserve bigger budgets and
be trusted with them because they clearly know
what they're doing um but like um just to labor
when you're going down to 50 000 or
twenty thousand dollars or whatever
it just means you have less and
less people working on the movie
your camera team is one person you know you have
a camera person a sound person and maybe one
other person and that's it um and so it's really
really hard to make a movie in that circum those
circumstances and there's no way i could have
made this movie under those circumstances um so
i had to make it at a certain level i could get
it down to this level i couldn't go any farther
were you cutting out locations or certain
characters yeah i carry i had to cut when i went
from the the version that was supposed to exist
in may it was cutting down locations and cutting
down characters but it was not cutting it was all
extraneous it was stuff that was not central to
um the story or more important to me was the
the themes uh that stuff if i can keep the the
the themes of the story um that stuff doesn't
get weakened then i can find a way to do it
uh that was the most important stuff uh important
thing to me but yeah so it's it's always the thing
like can you know what's the thing i teach my
students two people in a room that's cheap to do
you know if you can keep your and they're in
the same room you keep two people in a room
like that's that's the way to do low-budget
filmmaking once you add more rooms and add
more people it gets much more expensive and when
you talk to your students about sort of shrinking
it down and still having an effective story
how do they feel about that because so many
people they just like they say they want
to do transformers first yeah they hate it
they everybody hates it nobody i didn't i
hated it when i had to shrink the story i
hated it but um if you're gonna make
the movie you gotta make the movie
um with what you have um yeah no they hate it like
but it's part of the process like you gotta learn
like because what if you if they don't if i just
let them go if i didn't tell them that they had
to shrink something down or it's not going to be
physically possible then when the trump's actually
shooting it that's when they figure it out that
the oh i can't really do this and then by then
it's too late and then it's way too late so but
sometimes they have to go through that process of
you know they don't know what it's you don't
know what it's like until you've done it there's
nothing that prepares you for filmmaking there's
nothing like it and it's the only the only way you
can practice filmmaking is by making something
it's just the only way you can learn about it
did the one budget fall apart over a weekend
or uh we felt it coming but we thought we
were gonna get saved i mean you're hoping
against hope that you're gonna get saved but
then ultimately we got the message that nope not
gonna happen so then that was so it wasn't over
a weekend but there was just this like final
nail in the coffin thing that was brutal and so
this had been seven years at that point yeah
something like that sure okay and then how
are you dealing with that emotionally knowing that
okay you're gonna have to probably take people out
of the film take locations out yeah tear it down
i mean that that was that was brutal i mean it's
all these calls or emails that you got to send i
mean i had cast all those smaller parts um with
a bunch of actors you know around here around la
um and i had oh sorry you're the part's not i had
to cut your part and they all understood i mean
the actors were all great about that um i mean
that was like a death so when the money falls
out that was like a death like it was literally
because i could not when it first happened i
could not see a way to actually get the movie made
um so there was a grieving process with that
it's just like i had to grieve for a couple
days but then it was um again i go back to i'm i'm
stubborn as all hell and now i'm making this movie
so once i got over the fact that that that
this kind of death had happened and that i
then had to still figure out a way to make it
then it just becomes about figuring out a way
to make it then it again it gets to that question
like it's a problem that i've got to solve it's a
nut that i've gotta crack so how can i do it how
can i how can i do this at a level that's smaller
and so it's just figuring out those mechanics
and it meant cutting locations cutting actors
but once i saw what i was doing and that it
was not affecting um all of the central stuff
in the movie the central parts of the story the
central ideas of the story like and what the main
character is going through all of that stuff is
still there then i was fine it's like oh i can do
this like i can still make this like this other
stuff that i had it was it was not necessary so
we don't need that extra money i can't
get that extra money anyway so why have it
um it would have made the movie fuller
but it it would not it does not change
the movie does not change the core of the movie
so once i had gone through the the the sort of
you know as i said grieving process of it then
it's just about okay now i'm still climbing
this mountain it's that stubbornness of
i'm not i'm not giving up on i'm gonna
make this thing well it's almost a parallel
to what the story's about in some sense um
hmm i don't know i've never thought of it that way
um i it's just more of um i'll tell you what it
was one of the like what lessons do you learn you
learn for me or what i learn i learned that i will
even with all i mean mike mike ryan or my producer
my other producer sherry hefner they're great i
could not have done the film without them but
ultimately when you're making a movie you are
the reason that it's going to ultimately get made
because you're going to be the one who's going
to fight the hardest for it other people will
fight for it you will fight the hardest for it
if i'd has said that's it you know when that when
the money fell out if i'm the one if i go i give
up i'm not going to be able to do it you know
they want to try to talk me in for a little bit
but they've got other stuff that they're doing
too again that's the life of the producer you
got 15 things going some of them don't go and if
the if the director the writer director stops oh
okay i'm just going to move over again they're
not callous they're not being uh insensitive or
anything they got other stuff that they got to do
so that uh that was one of the main lessons like
you're gonna be the driving the main driving
force always um on this sort of stuff
i'm not sure whose statistic this is but 99 of
filmmakers never go on to make another feature
film do you have another one in you i know you're
still you're still wrapping this one up yeah i do
yeah i've got multiple things that are um
written um but you know that doesn't mean
that they're gonna happen i mean it's just it's
it's hard it's really hard to get a movie made
um you know if i don't make another feature
i'll make more stuff i'll make more shorts
but i like i don't suffer for um ideas um which
again that sounds really arrogant for me to say
that but um i um i feel like there's stuff that um
stuff that i want to make stuff that i think is um
interesting stuff that i think i have a a unique
perspective on that i want to try to get at um
and so and i don't know you're just
alive for it like when you want to do it
and i enjoy writing like i enjoy that part of
the process um and so when you're when you're um
when you want to do it like you're looking for
things that are going to help you create like um
something for a film an idea or a texture
or whatever and so you're kind of open to it
and looking so stuff sort of gets you fired
up like an idea or a moment or whatever and
see what you can generate from that but yeah
no i have i have two things written that um
i'd want to rewrite but yeah i'd be ready
to make where are you finding time to write
i mean you have such a full life all these
responsibilities well but like but that it's
when you enjoy it you find the time for
it and i didn't write them last weekend
you know i wrote uh the first drafts of those
a couple years ago you know um so but when you
when it's when it's you're getting something
out of it you don't it doesn't feel like a um
it doesn't feel like a task and i mean again this
is the this is the advantage of being a teacher
and having my summers off and um i can spend
time on that sort of stuff and um it's good
so you never the well never runs drive
no there's wow curse okay no there's a curse
no i mean like i larger ideas certainly or
things like worlds that i'd like to go into um
social like yeah i'm i'm really interested
in things like social class and economics and
certain things about um certain contexts and
certain aspects of like american identity
i'm really interested in that sort of stuff right
and so it's like oh it'd be interesting to make
a movie about that or a story that's focused
on that but i'm like everybody else like you
know oh i've got uh six pages here now what the
hell do i do you know i'm like the the well very
often runs dry or the well is very often full
with crappy ideas so um but i do feel like um
i do feel like that that that's a resource uh
i don't like it's it's not even i shouldn't
even say that i don't want for ideas i guess i'm
always searching for ideas maybe that's a better
way to say it i'm always looking for stuff
to write because once i find something that
that sparks me that's exciting and you're
trying to get that feeling always i think
um it's an intoxicating thing it's like a high
you know it's a good idea and you write it down
it's a good scene it was the one of the ones that
i'm talking about that i would like to make next
like i just the other day one good thing about
driving home from santa monica for two hours
is that you get ideas yeah yeah but but
i i was me alone in the car and like oh
there's a good idea i could do that in that
script and that's um that is intoxicating
like that's a great feeling it's like you get that
excitement for the thing because it's you know you
you the excitement can wane you know with an idea
and then all of a sudden you get a new idea and
you oh that's right i gotta crack that back open
and get back into that um i don't know i think
you always be seeking that that feeling you know
it was interesting to see like humphrey
bogart he either plays like a a screenwriter
that hasn't had a hit in years or he would
play you know a detective of course but um
just just oh you're a screenwriter you know
and it sounds so glamorous and then you see
like it's definitely difficult for him and sort
of this downtrodden you know mindset but having
to like keep himself revived i don't know it's
just i love seeing um films about screenwriters
oh yeah adaptation sunset boulevard is just
exquisite that the um oh god what is his name
oh my god well whatever what's that yeah it's
billy wilder filming i'm trying to think the
actor's name anyway you know he's the the
uh collection agencies are calling they're
trying to tow his car he just can't pay his rent
but then he meets this yeah but but that depiction
of the screenwriter which is so very honest um
yeah i always loved that right and also to uh
in a lonely place with humphrey bogart oh and
just you know his life seems very organized and
then um i don't want to give it away if anyone's
seen it even though so someone told me that if
a movie is older than 30 years i guess you can
give spoilers oh i spoil stuff all the time in
class that's half my job is spoiling the movie but
you know he's he's accused of this crime and and
um you just you know these women are so intrigued
because he's this screenwriter or whatever and
um and he has a number of things that have gotten
him into trouble i don't know where i'm going with
it but i just find it uh i don't know it seems
glamorous but it it's right it's probably when
you're in horrible la traffic that spark of it's
not sitting at this typewriter you know with sort
of the in this immaculate apartment as humphrey
bogart was seen in a lonely place that this
these ideas are coming it's in those kind of
moments where you want to check out yeah that's
where it's coming yeah but i mean i think it's
also like we're our projections of everything like
we want to project well all them you know because
um their life is probably better than mine because
they get to do this or they're doing that and they
don't nah everybody's life is essentially the same
like there is the drudgery of everything the
drudgery of screenwriting the drudgery of teaching
the drudgery of working customer
service the treasury of whatever
um it's all the same and there's there's you
know for 99.9 of the people of it there is
little to no glamour there's no glamour in it and
it's um um but the the one thing the advantage
of this because it is it's filled
with all that stress it's filled with
very little to no validation for your work i mean
that's the other thing about being a filmmaker is
no one may ever care about what you're doing um
and so you got to sort of accept that um or a very
small number of people may ever care um but um
like the the advantage of it is for the most part
i don't we wouldn't do it if we didn't really
love the thing because it's so hard to do
and there can be no validation for it at
the end of it so you have to enjoy it you
have to enjoy the process i wrote a i wrote
a little thing where you were talking about
the the seed and spark um i wrote a thing for
um filmmaker magazine while i was doing that
just like a little uh post for their online um
anyway and and the the gist of it was is that the
the dream of making a the movie or dream of
doing this is not about any kind of success
however you're going to define that but it's
really about the making because that's the
thing that's the most pleasurable like is is
the the making is the you know finding the
finding the right frame finding the right cut
finding the right piece of music finding the right
dialogue watching brian garrity and a
close-up and going oh my god this guy is
just such a good actor or whatever it's that
stuff that's going to be the thing that um
that lasts the other stuff will not last so
that's the dream of it at least to me at what
point did you approach brian garrity to be the
protagonist in faith uh so we uh so when that
whole thing happened and when we lost the money
we had other actors attached uh and another
actor attached to that the lead part chris um and
another a different actor attached for the pastor
and those guys are great guys and i love them
and they have been attached for almost a year
to play the parts and so i had again another part
of this these horrible phone calls and i have to
call them and tell them that the money's falling
out and they were both so disappointed they felt
so bad for me they're just there's they're good
people they're sweet guys and they were both
willing to um stay on because i said look i'm
gonna i'm gonna try like hell to still make this
movie and they say hey as long as we can make the
schedules work we'll do it um but then of course
we couldn't make the schedules work one of them
um one of them had a big tv show and the other one
was a lead in a broadway play right when we were
shooting the movie and so it just didn't work and
so then it's a scramble like okay how do we um
how do we replace these guys who were you know
not not huge stars but like known actors
and really really good actors and so um
brian garrity was suggested to me and a friend
of a friend was able to get him to the script
and he read it and he liked it and um he was
available like he'd been doing that show the
alienness to the tnt thing but then he was
off and he didn't have anything again until
i don't remember what whatever the schedule
worked and uh so we met and we got along and
and um he could see what i was trying to
do and i could see how he fit in the part
and um yeah it was good you know it's just luck
there's a lot of luck so you know that happens
here too we just happened to know somebody
who could get in the script and he fit and
and he was um known enough to where we could hold
on i mean this is this is the kind of cynical part
of this business but he's um known enough to
where we could hold on to some money you know
the hurt locker and boardwalk empire chicago
pd all this stuff it means something for um
financing obviously so yeah what's your first
week working on a new idea like like what are you
if you've gotten this idea while you're in traffic
or wherever it is standing line at the supermarket
but then you're actually okay i'm going to
invest time in this what's it like uh it's
just notes so i'm very organized disorganized
um it's it's it's a notebook where i am just i'm
writing either lines of dialogue ideas for seeing
something about a character character breakdown
any number of things that i think or a theme
something that i want somebody to say i don't
even know what character would say it but this is
a line that i want something where it's happening
um it's that it's a bunch of that i don't do the
note card thing i don't i will i will write a
series of notes i might even from those notes
like i'll fill up one of those like those black i
don't know if i have any of those black notebooks
you know the things that in seven where the guy
used to make all his notes right one of those
i'll fill one of those up and i might write
a draft out of that that draft will suck
but i have something and then i might then make
an outline from the draft so i've got notes that
i turn into a draft that i will then turn into
an outline defined structure i don't like to
structure first because i'm not as interested
in plot i'm i'm really not that interested in
plot at all i'm much more interested in character
and theme and so it's about um ideas and how i'm
trying to express those ideas whether it's through
characters actions or their context or whatever um
and so i found that if i try to impose structure
first which is what i think of as outline being is
a structural thing that then i get too focused
on the mechanics of plot which i don't care
about at all i want it to be about character and
characters journey however you want to describe it
so that's why outline actually comes for me
after i've written a draft so that i can then okay
here are all these ideas are there a way i can
structure these ideas now okay if that makes sense
so it's not an efficient way like if i was like on
for hire for a script i probably couldn't do it
that way but i'm nobody's knocking on my door to
do that pay me a bunch of money to write a script
for them so this way allows me to um to hold on to
the things that i think are more important because
if i'm worried about these kind of story beats and
steps and because american movies are all about
causality this causes this causes this causes this
then i might lose the character because if the
character is doing things that are contradictory
there's not a clear causality between them that
might be way more interesting than if there is
um so that's kind of way whether that happens over
a week i don't know i've got two kids now who the
hell knows how long it'll take me to get to those
places it might get me i might get to a draft in a
week but i kind of doubt it um that first week is
probably just going to be notes notes notes notes
notes and trying to figure out who it is and
then when you actually get a first draft down
are you doing the sort of putting it away
and then looking at it again yeah that's
generally what i found is the best thing it's um
i want to i want to look at it with fresh eyes
i'm not sending it to anybody yet because it's not
good enough yet you don't want to waste people's
time and i don't want to get a bunch of notes from
i don't waste their time and i also don't want to
get a bunch of notes for stuff that i'll of course
i know what's wrong with it right after i look at
it a second time um so it's don't look at it for
whatever a couple weeks a month something like
that um and then go back in and look at it and
um hopefully do a pretty significant teardown
of it um pieces of it will survive but it should
be a pretty significant teardown because the first
thing shouldn't be very good it should um you're
trying to get some ideas out uh you're trying to
work around those ideas but um it's not gonna be
anywhere near what the finished product i mean
that first draft of faith from 10 years ago was
vastly different than the thing the movie that
we shot you still have it yeah somewhere it's on a
thumb drive somewhere yeah where did you write it
i did the uh the very cliched thing this was
before i had kids so i could do this as i i
uh went to i went up the coast and i just
rented a hotel for like two or three days and
banged out the first draft i mean i had a whole
bunch of it sort of worked out so it wasn't like a
what's my idea and three days later i had to
finish draft of the script i had a whole bunch
of notes and stuff that i was working from but
yeah did you see it like an ocean view hotel uh
no i don't i didn't have the money to afford
that but it was by the ocean here oh it sounds
so romantic yeah yeah yeah i know i did that so
but yeah good luck me convincing my wife to let
me do that again now leave her with two kids so
i can go right i don't think that's gonna happen
did you do it with a laptop or did you
get right in yeah no yeah i'm i'm too lazy
i'm too lazy to do long form i've uh that
was one thing that like i had final draft
very early on when i was still an undergrad and
i've just gotten used to writing that way was the
was going back to that 10-year hotel stay was that
taking clock worth it in terms of it actually got
you to finish it because you're like i'm here i
paid for this yeah i know it helped but that that
it helped i'm sure i can't remember it so long
ago um but it was also like it was good to just
um that was just the thing i was there to do it
was just that you know nothing else um it was
a good feeling and also the the idea felt like
you have times when you're reaching for the idea
like you're you're writing and but you're still
reaching for the idea the idea was like close
enough to where i could do it in that three days
time you know get it out there's other scripts or
the idea is not close enough to where i wouldn't
be able to get it all out in three days time
if that makes any sense it does yeah
that's interesting how many drafts of
faith did you write before you sent it to
your producer mike i had probably written
three maybe four something like that i want to say
i'd have to go back and look but i want to say it
was three or four drafts and it's a yeah like i
said it's a vastly different script than the one
um that we ended up shooting that thematically
it's the same uh structurally and character-wise
it's a little bit different so three or four
drafts in you send it to him what's his time
frame for getting back to you what were the
notes uh he got back to me probably within
three weeks something like that again i won't
make it sound like i just sent it to him like
there was plenty of people i sent it to who
didn't respond um but it was kind of in his
wheelhouse like it's he was he told me when he
was like 14 he was thinking about being a priest
oh wow um but then girls and so then you know
girls happen to be yeah exactly um and um his his
response i mean he responded the script he said i
like the way it's dealing with these kinds of um
with issue these kinds of issues but no judgment
to the characters um and then he had a few ideas
for the ending as i recall or i don't know so
then we we talked on the phone about it and um
he suggested i do another like scene outline so
i did a scene outline and then he came out to la
because he was here he's a new york based producer
he was here because one of his films was i was
around the independent spirit awards i remember
that and one of his films was nominated for i
think was one of the actors or something and so
then we got to meet and talk face to face and he
suggested a big change i originally the story
was actually divided between two characters
who's two different stories going on and he
suggested just to simplify it to just focus
on one character for a number of reasons he
said don't change the the again it's the themes
the ideas all that stuff stays the same you
just got to simplify the story so it's just
one person's story um so i did that and he was
he responded really positively to that rewrite
and so then we were kind of off and running in
terms of then trying to generate interest we
ended up out i ended up out in new york through
with ifp they had a this kind of screenplay what
did they call it this program that's emergency
emerging storytellers where they selected it was
a pretty competitive program they only select
x number of scripts and then we got to meet
uh with like sony classics and i don't remember
a bunch of different companies you know trying
to generate interest see if you can get any
money we didn't get any money um but uh but
it was a really good thing and and um and then
it was i rewrote a couple more drafts and then
eventually we got there do you think the themes
in faith are ones that people can relate to
even if they're you know non-denominational
they're not part of a church even if they
don't consider themselves religious yeah i mean i
think i i think the audience for it will probably
be more people who consider themselves agnostic um
more so than well i don't know god sorry sorry um
i think the audience four will probably
be people who consider themselves
uh agnostic i mean i don't know we there
might be some um some regular church goers who
who are interested in it too um but yeah i mean
especially people who maybe went to church as um
when they were kids and now aren't as connected to
it um i think they probably will respond to it um
but we'll see i don't know i mean that's a big
thing now is like you uh you're supposed to
figure out who your audience is beforehand
right i'm not i'm not as comfortable with
that uh just because i feel like
you're um i want to make the thing
i want to make the thing that's in my
head that i think is interesting without
thinking about who else is going to find it
interesting not because i don't think or don't
want anybody else to find it interesting but i'm
too i'm worried that if i focus too much on what
other people are thinking about it then i'll lose
the thread of what's interesting about it to me
the hope is that if it's interesting to me it's
going to be interesting to other people if we do
it well enough and that will hopefully be enough
to get in a big enough audience to um make the
movie worthwhile um but who knows um i just i
like the i know several people who are sort of
involved in this like marketing and distribution
before you make the movie and i understand it
because of these things we've been talking about
in terms of the lack of funding and trying to
get your money back from a movie i completely
understand it but just as a as the writer director
in me is like i can't think about that stuff
or else all of a sudden you're worried about
this choice and how it fits in the film you're not
worried about if it fits in the the the world of
the film you're worried about how other people are
going to respond to it and i just i it's anathema
to me i just i can't i don't want to do it so i
don't know we'll see you know you you uh you hope
you hope that you've done something that enough
people will respond to because there's you know
people have um put their faith in you and and um
put some money behind the movie and and so um you
don't want to disappoint him you wanted to you
want that faith to be rewarded so here's hoping